or the British Medical Association is
balloting Junior doctors now over a
future strike it's chair Dr Philip
Banfield is with us now thanks so much
for being with us good morning Sophie um
first of all can you just give us a bit
of an honest appraisal about what it's
actually like to work with the NHS right
now well our members have have never
seen so much uh stress so much moral
injury from not being able to undertake
the care that they're so desperate to
give
um this has arisen because we just don't
have enough beds for the Health Service
need at this point in time now part of
that is not being able to discharge
people from hospital and that creates a
a kind of Log Jam but this is years and
years of running down the number of beds
so we've got half the number of beds
available to the Health Service that we
did 30 years ago you talk about years
and years I think that is quite
important isn't it because
um the government often talks a lot
about covered and says that this is a
part of the knock-on effect of the
pandemic is that right what the pandemic
has done is is aggravate a situation
that was deteriorating and we have been
highlighting really for 10 years or more
so you know if you look at the figures
the waiting list had gone from 2.6 to
4.4 million before the pandemic you know
it's gone over 7 million now this is an
absolute National scandal
we spoke a program last week to at the
chair of the sort of acute emergency
medicine and he was talking about in
fact this basically means people dying
and if an ambulance can't get to them in
time if they're waiting for a e you know
is that is that the brutal reality then
uh that's a really good word even he's
brutal on the front line uh at the
moment we see our GP colleagues you know
buckling under the weight not only of of
people who are worried about things that
are going on now but they're bearing the
the brunt of the backlog because you
know people keep going to their their GP
and what does that mean does that mean
like you know hundreds of people trying
to call eight in the morning to try and
get an appointment and failing to well
well it does it means that they're
filling the face-to-face slots and
having 30 40 50 online consultations as
well to try and fit in but what it
translates to is
you know patients making conscious
decisions with their GPS not to go to
hospital when they when they need to
because they don't want to languish on a
a hospital uh trolley and my wife who is
a is a GP had 12 hours on a on an a e
trolley with uh chest pain thinking that
she was going to to die on her own
because I wasn't around at the time and
you know this is the kind of trauma that
is being suffered by patients and the
staff could not be trying harder you
know there's no fault on the staff how
on Earth emergency departments staff
keep going and we do know that it's
affecting their mental health and we do
know that it's causing burnout I'm
really sorry to hear about your wife
that's like incredibly sort of stressful
situation for her and also for you she's
better now that's going to work so I'm
glad but it does I guess highlight what
so many people are experiencing and
we've seen nurses and ambulance workers
going on strike at Doctor strikes
inevitable all uh they're not inevitable
at all we're balloting at the moment and
the result will come in five weeks time
and now is the time for us to get down
with government and vice versa to find a
resolution to this now we met with the
Secretary of State for the first time
but actually now that we've done that it
was uh not as negative as I was
expecting
um there are things that the Secretary
of State can do business with us over
and and that would include trying to
give back confidence in the pay review
bodies for example but there are things
as he points out that it's the Prime
Minister and chancellor who are
controlling
um and uh he made the same offer to us
as he's made to the other unions which
is try and help him with the economic
argument and the economic argument is
strong we're spending a lot of money on
locums with the the fact that the
the health and wealth of the population
is deteriorating and that gap between
the poor and the rich is widening and
that translates into you know an
economic crisis as well and you know it
doesn't make sense uh to make people
sicker and we know that the country is
getting sicker as a whole
let's get people back into work then
they can pay their taxes so uh you know
I for me it's a very straightforward uh
Market uh economics argument uh doctors
are leaving the NHS they've got choice
these are bright young graduates
um you know their entry pay just over 14
pounds an hour you know full pay
restoration for them means 18 pounds an
hour you know we have to decide as a
country what the value for the expertise
for junior doctors is and Junior doctor
us are not Junior by any means these are
skilled highly trained professionals and
I'm interested quite heartened I guess
to say that you think that it perhaps
wasn't quite as negative as you would
expect when you met with a health
secretary
um Steve Barkley and do you think that
he's willing to move on pay if you get
back a bit on reform that was that
effectively what happened well I've met
him for just over an hour right that's
the first time that that I've met
um so you know it is all for what
happens next
um and the indications are that we will
be having that dialogue while we're
having dialogue there's always the
possibility of averting industrial
action no doctor wants to go on strike
no nurse wants to go on strike we feel
that we're being backed into it
um I'm interested to get your thoughts
on Labor's position as well uh kissed
armor in an interview today with the
Sunday Telegraph so the NHS must reform
will die and the idea that the service
is still the Envy of the world is wrong
is he right
well when the NHS works it is superb is
it worth right now you cannot beat it
and they're a pocket there are times
when it works it's not working for
everyone
right so there are some really really
brilliant bits of the NHS that happen
day in and day out and we are
emphasizing that the NHS is the future
for this country because it should be
the most effective and efficient Health
Service you can have because if you
don't take profit out of it that money
should be available
but I mean labor says that they would
like to for example uh bypass GPS allow
people to have safe self-refer is that
is that a good idea I met with
registrating this uh week and we had to
agree to disagree that he doesn't
understand general practice
um and you know the GPS are one of the
most efficient and effective parts of
the Health Service in the way that they
manage risk they are superb at it so you
don't think that labor really
understands how the GP system works well
I think that they have a lot of work to
do between now and an election we have
offered to help them with that we'll do
business with anyone who has the right
policies this is not about Party
politics for us as a BMI so why is
self-refer a bad idea because some
people think look it's obvious you know
I can't get through to my GP um I can
just self-refer way more efficient
um it's not efficient from the point of
view that uh what tends to happen is you
have people who are the worried well and
the people who really have an issue say
I don't want to bother my doctor right I
don't want to have
um uh take up someone else's time so you
then end up
paradoxically with a widening Health
inequality because some people will just
refer themselves straight to
um Specialists when actually they don't
need to be correct okay understood
um I mean I guess what West rooting
would say is that you may be part of the
problem he's described the BMA as
hostile to his plans he says he's not
afraid to take on the doctors and
Kirsten as well telling me last weekend
we've got to have battles my experience
of Reform is there will always be people
who say I wouldn't do that I disregard
that we're not going to back down the
first time someone says I wouldn't back
down or I wouldn't do this
they're willing to go into battle with
you doctors are not the problem they are
the solution
you need the us as experts to deal with
the problems of the NHS we are not
averse to change it's a complete fallacy
that doctors want in a Health Service to
stay as it is we're the first people to
say we want change in the Health Service
but please can we have it evidence-based
please can you listen to Frontline staff
and please can you invest properly in a
Health Service we can be proud of uh
really interesting to talk thanks so
much to be uh on the for being on the
program thank you so much thank you